welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Hector Navarro and today I'm breaking
down one of the most recent depictions
of the story of Captain America his
origin his allies his victories his
failures and the love of his life no I'm
not talking about Bucky but close and it
all lives in a pretty unlikely place the
theater that's right I'm talking about
Rogers the musical the extended version
of the fictional stage show we saw at
the beginning of the Hawkeye Disney plus
series that is now real and currently
playing at the Disney California
Adventure theme park right next to
Disneyland here on the West Coast so
before we can start belting out our
rendition of save the city I gotta
remind you that new rockstars is now
three channels this main one the break
room and the Deep dive so make sure
you're subscribed to all three because
it's free entertainment and it helps us
out a lot alright it's show time let's
get into the production history of this
amazing one act musical playing at the
Hyperion theater in hollywoodland at
California Adventure and how it all
started with the Hawkeye version we saw
on Disney Plus clearly taking
inspiration from the real-life Broadway
Mega hit Hamilton the fictional Rogers
the musical was thought up by Hawkeye's
head writer Jonathan igla and was
approved to be added to the show after
Hawkeye director Rhys Thomas pitched it
to Kevin feige feige then reached out to
composer and Lyricist Mark Shaman after
they met at a Mary Poppins returns event
and Shaman and composer and Lyricist
Scott Whitman wrote the number saved the
city imagining it to be the final number
of act one of a longer stage musical in
the first episode of Hawkeye Clint
Barton takes his kids to see Rogers
during a vacation in New York City and
the show reminds Barton of the loss of
his best friend Natasha Romanoff the
Black Widow during the events of
Avengers end game and when that first
episode dropped save the city became a
huge hit with fans praising its
cheesiness and great in-universe
inaccuracies that added World building
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
song was released as a single and even
added to the second volume of the
Hawkeye soundtrack those in Universe
inaccuracies like how Ant-Man was
written as being present during the
Battle of New York from the first
Avengers movie in 2012 even though we
know he wasn't there led to fans
speculation about how much information
the general public in the MCU had about
major Earth threatening events then the
Miss Marvel show revealed that the
public would get a lot of information
about the fight in endgame second hand
like through Scott Lang's appearances on
podcasts boy Ant-Man is really at the
center of the Public's perceptions of
the Avengers huh maybe it makes sense as
to why Scott wrote a book to capitalize
on his Newfound popularity look out for
the little guy out later this year
pre-order your copy today that's a real
book they really made it a book so after
Hawkeye was released in 2021 save the
city was performed live last year at the
d23 Expo in 2022 and after that we
learned in January of this year 2023
that an extended version of Rogers the
musical was being developed as a
30-minute one-act play to be performed
at California Adventure Christopher
Leonards who's the musical composer for
the Amazon series the boys and who also
did the music for the agent Carter one
shot and the agent Carter television
series would be hired to be the
conductor and a ranger for the musical
writing music for five original songs at
the musical anatomy of a superhero panel
during this year's San Diego Comic-Con
moderated by Michael chiquino
Christopher Leonards talked about how
everyone working on the musical agreed
that the key to expanding the save the
city song into a larger story
surrounding Steve Rogers was to zero in
on the Love Story between him and Peggy
Carter because quote love stories make
the best musicals and that became the
backbone for the entirety of Rogers the
musical and Michael jokino also
confirmed at that panel that Kevin feige
loves musicals so there you go use that
information however you like executive
creative director for Disney live
entertainment Dan Fields shared on the
this week in Marvel podcast that
although Rogers the musical was played
far sickly in the Hawkeye Disney Plus
show because it had to be to help Clint
Barton in his journey when expanding
this out they decided that the rest of
the show didn't have to be in that tone
and they were right also another fun
detail about the show is because it's
been on during the release of the secret
Invasion series we've seen a scroll
Usher stepping outside of the theater
and walking around from time to time a
great addition to the Marvel Disney plus
costume character appearances around the
California Adventure Park following in
the tradition of Moon Knight or werewolf
by night or president Loki specific to
whatever Disney Plus show was airing at
the time also a shout out to ordinary
Adventures for letting us use their
footage of Rogers the musical go check
out their YouTube channel covering theme
parks across the country there is a link
in the description thanks guys so now
we're almost ready to start the show
during the pre-show while everyone is
finding a seat and getting comfortable
there's a radio on stage playing old
school and I mean old school jazz music
of the early 20th century time period
like the kind Steve Rogers grew up with
one of the songs is Bugle Call Rag by
Benny Goodman which Eagle eared MCU fans
would recognize from the first episode
of what if what if Captain Carter were
the First Avenger that is played during
the Montage where Peggy Carter is just
wamping Nazi Hydra Goons
love that song gets me pumped and after
the announcer kicks us off we meet the
starkettes three women who act like the
classic Greek chorus or the muses in the
animated Hercules movie based on the
women on stage during Howard Stark's
presentation of his hover car at the
world exposition of tomorrow in Captain
America the First Avenger who begin the
U.S opening song introducing us to main
man Steve Rogers when he was still
normal Steve or his fans affectionately
refer to him skinny Steve with a little
bit of that Alan Silvestri score from
the First Avenger plus we briefly meet
Peggy Carter and James Buchanan Bucky
Barnes who's already enlisted in the
107th Division and Steve yells after him
don't win the war till I get there the
first two-thirds of the Rogers show are
basically a retelling of Captain America
the First Avengers so expect to hear a
lot of familiar lines shout out to
writers U.S opening also has a reference
to 1A which is what Steve needed to be
classified to be approved for the Army
the next song is I want you referencing
the giant Uncle Sam recruitment poster
hanging in the background but it's
really Disney princess Steve Rogers I
Want song and it's incredible my
favorite new song of the entire show
Rogers the musical can be summed up by
this song and it's a love letter to the
creators of Captain America artist Jack
Kirby and writer Joe Simon who put so
much of themselves into this character
and who had Captain America punching
Adolf Hitler on the cover of his first
comic an entire year before the United
States entered World War II this is why
this show works because Steve Rogers is
such an Earnest heartfelt guy who knows
what to stand up for helping people
however he can it's a testament to the
genius of Jack Kirby and Joe Simon and
all the writers and artists who have
contributed to Captain America over the
decades it's in this I want you song we
also get our first utterance of I can do
this all day don't worry it'll come back
we finally meet Dr Abraham Erskine
played by the same actor who played
Bucky earlier and the return of Agent
Carter we hear more lines lifted from
the First Avenger so you want to go
overseas and kill some Nazis I don't
want to kill anybody I don't like
bullies I don't care where they're from
the experience government Begins the
next song is a brilliant incorporation
of Star-Spangled man from Captain
America the First Avenger which was
written by Alan Menken and David Zippel
we cut to the Vita Ray experiment to
make Steve a super soldier we hear some
classic skinny Steve awkwardness with
maybe you shouldn't examine me in front
of a beautiful Dame woman agent Peggy
replies with you have no idea how to
talk to women do you this is the longest
conversation I've ever had with one
women aren't exactly lining up to dance
with a guy they might step on maybe you
just haven't found the right Patna
Rogers the musical does a wonderful job
of picking up these incredibly important
moments for Steve Rogers and stuffing
them into the fun and inspiring musical
numbers in fact after some more lines
from the First Avenger Professor Erskine
asking Steve that whatever happens
promise me that you'll stay who you are
not a perfect Soldier but a good man we
can hear the yell coming from the
chamber no I can do this it's no
surprise that this leads to a cheer
moment from the live audience when Steve
emerges just like the improvised moment
from actress Haley Atwell who played
Peggy car in the movie Peggy on stage
touches Steve's chest hey if you want
Broadway level skin and hair care at a
community theater budget let me tell you
a little bit about our friends over at
geology geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products use just a handful of
proven powerful ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you gotta do is take a quick
30 second quiz right now if you use code
new rockstars 100 geology will give you
100 off of their award-winning skin care
trial set let me say that again 100 off
of their award winning skincare trial
set you'll also get an additional bonus
offer of up to 30 off of one skin hair
or body product when you add it to your
trial it's truly a wild offer one of the
best they've ever given our audience
click on the link in the description or
go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started next we meet
a colonel probably the show's version of
Chester Phillips as we move into the
corny USO tour all still hearing the
amazing Star-Spangled man just like in
the movie Steve suits up with the
leather jacket look just like Cap's
first unofficial outing as Captain
America when he disobeyed orders to save
Bucky and the 107th in the First Avenger
then at the end of this number streamers
yay red white and blue paper next Peggy
appears to tell Steve that the 107's
been captured we get a little bit of
Just One Dance singling out Steve and
Peggy's tragic romance that never was
back to Star Spangled man we get the war
Montage The Howling Commandos are
mentioned so our Red Skull and Hydra
being defeated by Steve Captain Roger
saving his childhood best friend Bucky
and the 107th all while seeing a really
cool comic book panel Montage on stage
perfectly framing these moments in
Steve's life again it's another tribute
and reminder of the character's comic
book Origins where all this started the
comics thanks Joe and Jack the end of
the number brings up the window of the
red skulls bomber plane the valkyrie
Peggy is at the desk on the radio stage
left and we all know what's coming next
heartbreak tragedy no mention of the
Stork Club though probably because it's
too hard to rhyme then static Steve
sleeps and we hear the ticking of a
clock even a dial-up internet noise not
a brain loading noise it's a dial-up
internet noise that's what it is you
young people I'm not that old that
everybody knows that the country moves
on we hear Shield agents say we found
them this one's waited long enough just
like the opening two Captain America the
First Avenger then the biggest comedic
number of the show is next what you
missed which is our introduction to Nick
Fury director of Shield played by the
same actor who played the World War II
Colonel briefly earlier what you missed
may be inspired by the song in Hamilton
what did I miss and It just fits so
perfectly Steve is sitting in a bed
getting caught up on the past 70 years
the role of Nick Fury in this is
hilarious and comparisons made to the
role of the genie in the Aladdin stage
show are accurate he's the comic relief
he sings he dances it's Nick Fury how
you've never seen him before where's my
spot he yells then he says here's a
notebook Steve that's a reference to the
notebook that Steve pulled out at the
beginning of Captain America the Winter
Soldier some of the pop culture and
history Fury rattles off includes the
show I Love Lucy which one division
seemed to pull a lot of inspiration from
Darth Vader being Luke Skywalker's dad
in the background during what you missed
we see a billboard for The Lion King
stage show another massive hit in the
Broadway World and an ad for the world
exposition of tomorrow may be similar to
the Stark expo from Iron Man 2 and we
finally get to Fury introducing Steve to
the concept of the Avengers there's an
idea to bring together a group of
remarkable people to accomplish a task
to be something greater just like we
heard in the first Avengers movie and
when the Rogers the musical Avengers
appear the crowd loses their minds they
go nuts these are the same Avengers we
saw in save the city on Hawkeye with
their casual looks as opposed to like
full-on superhero outfits and we'll see
them again later when save the city
starts up again you better believe don't
worry Fury calls Steve the First Avenger
then mentions Captain Marvel off Planet
so not I ideal Iron Man Hulk Thor Black
Widow Ant-Man who again wasn't actually
there but this is all based on knowledge
the in-universe public thinks they know
and Hawkeye who Fury says is quote here
as well making us think this little jab
at Hawkeye just adds to the discomfort
and annoyance Clint Barton would have
felt watching the show with his kids the
rest of the Avengers Nick Fury lists off
but we don't see our black panther Wanda
maximoff the legendary Star-Lord the
vision the Falcon The Amazing Spider-Man
The Man Without Fear Daredevil Rocket
and Groot who doesn't know yet that he's
a raccoon a pair of sisters blue and
green that's nebula and Gamora Daughters
of Thanos the Winter Soldier who Furious
surprisingly breezes over it's like uh
buddy Steve might want to know about
that guy War Machine and Doctor Strange
then Steve is given a winter soldier
style jacket to whereas his Captain
America costume for the remainder of the
show and finally we get to save this
city but a shorter version than the full
thing they previously recorded for
Hawkeye Steve pulls a shirt change
ditching his white shirt for a blue one
with a star on it completing the Captain
America look the actor who plays Erskine
is now a New York Citizen and fury is
now a really cool looking Loki the song
brings back the iconic line I can do
this all day but brings it back again at
the end with a really somber version
after more and more catastrophes plague
the planet and Steve gets tired of all
the fighting an announcement blares out
attention citizens of sokovia the city
is under attack by artificial
intelligence referencing the events of
Avengers Age of Ultron then another
attention Washington DC the city is
under attack by the Winter Soldier but
curiously this is placed here in the
show where in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Hydra attacked DC in 2014 and
Ultron attacked in 2015. so maybe this
was swapped around to keep adding those
inaccuracies or because the producers of
the show didn't want to make it seem
like Bucky storyline was going to take
Focus but instead the focus here is on
Steve continuing to fight and fight and
fight exhausting himself next is the
announcement that wakanda is under
attack by Thanos referencing Avengers
Infinity war and Steve is looking tired
we'd be tired too buddy we'd be tired
too and that's when Steve meets Old Man
Steve Rogers played by the actor who
plays skinny Steve with a familiar on
your left sending chills down our spines
Old Man Steve pulls out the time Stone
because endings can be Rewritten then he
sits down on a bench just like in
Avengers end game the final new song in
the show is end of the line and it's
Steve singing with Steve they even move
their legs when they sit down the same
so here I am now and also then current
Steve is looking into the past seeing
images of himself before the Super
soldier's serum then him holding mjolnir
at the Battle of Earth in Avengers end
game what looks like the Winter Soldier
and then even Sam Wilson as cap in the
future but who's waiting at the end of
the line Peggy Carter in her iconic hat
and suit from the agent Carter 2 Season
should have been more television series
the clock is ticking and current Steve
is back in the past Peggy Carter is in
her beautiful red dress from the bar
scene in the First Avenger Steve's late
but he's here the audience gets what
we've been waiting for the reprise of
the song Just One Dance a dance between
Steve and Peggy and I can do this all
day kiss it is emotional oh boy you try
not to cry okay it's hard all right
hard finally the show ends with the last
song a reprise of save the city because
of course they want you humming that on
your way out the door overall Rogers the
musical is fantastic it's romantic and
fun and silly and Earnest and it's a
love letter to the character of Steve
Rogers Captain America even when the
show tries to poke fun at the
Ridiculousness of the whole concept a
musical based on a Marvel Superhero it
can't help but take the character
seriously and to me that's a testament
to the creators Joe Simon and Jack Kirby
who Infuse this comic book hero with
real New Yorker bravery and heroism
Steve Rogers is the type of person we
should all strive to be like so thanks
Jack and Joe for creating him we've
learned Rogers the musical will be
closing on August 31st at the end of
this month and that's a shame
considering how great the show is and
how much work was put into it but
hopefully it can make a return to the
Hyperion at California Adventure in the
future maybe with some updated elements
as more and more of the Marvel Cinematic
universe unfolds in theory theaters and
on our TV screens maybe we can get a
Wilson the musical update chronicling
the life of Sam Wilson Captain America
or uh Carter the musical that shows us
the alternate history of Peggy Carter
being the one given the super soldier
serum either way Rogers the musical has
been a really fun addition to the MCU
and one that fans are going to carry
with them for a very long time now
hopefully we can get a release of the
music so fans can enjoy listening to it
over and over again adding to its
popularity just like what happened with
Hamilton and encouraging California
Adventure to bring the show back in a
big way so that's all for us today folks
thanks so much for watching make sure
you subscribe to all three new rockstars
channels and we'll see you next time bye
[Music]